what's up everybody it's me Chris and on
today's local boutique breakdown I want
to share with you three concepts that
will make you a better designer hard to
believe the truth
today's logo critique features Elvin
bass who we brought in as a special
guest to help me critique we've selected
three logo critiques each one will
relate to one of these concepts
critiquing process simplicity research
now I'm gonna play the clips afterwards
we'll go a little bit more in depth with
these three concepts and how to use them
to prove your design okay this one was
submitted by Cody James Freebo
I really like the direction of this logo
but this is pay per click alright
yeah paper clip and this is a paper clip
in there so just a little correction
like that I would do is to use another
typeface instead of just stick thicker
type do so so what did Yellen do he
picked a typeface that was more
complementary to the form itself he just
happened to know that Abel's gonna work
because it has certain kind of round
forms and so what we talk about is like
repetition and contrast the contrast is
it's the paperclip the repetition is we
share similar letter form drawing kind
of arcs right so it shares that and then
he started making decisions about how to
make this read better so the eye needs
to be pulled apart which he started to
break that and then he started to break
the top of the paperclip to the bottom
and I think this is one of those logos
where you can read and then you gotta
wait a minute I think there's a paper
clipping mm-hm
and that is how you do what ladies and
gentlemen this is a company called top
story so Roberto a good job on this one
there's some good things in here and
there's some busted up things the T and
the S that's pretty cool I like that a
lot that's really handsome it's bold its
geometric these three other elements
you're like they're not even talking to
each other this seems like a
dysfunctional family where the father
doesn't talk to the mother nor the
cousin of the kid or anything like that
nobody's talking to anybody the TM is
too far away the top story is a totally
different typeface and it's in black and
it's upper lower case
where everything else is uppercase and
then you have leader in world news as
all lowercase in gray can you get a more
kind of weird mishmash to things going
on
simplify simplify simplify yes is from
Zachary black did a mark another lion my
feeling is this
I like these kind of mono line logos
like a single weight mm-hmm but here's
the problem I just think the line is
such a majestic animal it's the king of
the jungle
and the proportion of the lion's head to
the body to his feet feel really funny
to me it's almost like one of those
bobblehead characters and it's not
working for me okay so I think I would
love for you to take this exact same
style in your illustration skills and
rebalance it like we wanted something
that feels really regal and majestic
right yeah that's a nice one there's a
couple things in there so probably the
first step is just a look at what's been
done just to kind of see how other
people solve the same problem but here's
what I'm thinking
what are you thinking you don't need the
body okay so I would delete the body and
really build the mane of the lion mm-hmm
and make sure that the lion's head reads
so we probably need to look at some
references for a lion head in the
profile view okay so first off I'd like
to point out that although Gellin is a
great designer clear foreign letterform
artist his critiquing style could use a
little work I look at critiquing like a
train the first car is the logo the
cause of this critique the last car the
caboose is the things that we need to
fix I start my critiques by simply
describing what I'm seeing what's
clearly there the typefaces shapes
colors no judgments let's just take it
all in then I start to notice how
certain things make me feel and I
describe them using phrases like this
feels out of place or I like this we're
getting closer to the caboose and I feel
like it could start getting a little bit
more critical I point out things that
aren't working and why the second
critique focus on the concept of
simplicity there were too many different
things going on and there was no
interplay or cohesion between all the
elements the solution simplify use less
typefaces fewer point sizes and fewer
colors a good technique I use is to hide
everything when I know it's not working
are adding back things one element at a
time before I start designing anything I
go on the internet and look at what's
been done before I try to find
contextual references research history
literature films photography whatever
just look at stuff and let your brain
soak it in don't forget to go to the
source if for example you're designing a
lion head logo look at photos and videos
of real lions go to the zoo and stare
one or better yet go on uh so far and
stock it for a week the more research
you do the deeper you go the better your
thing will be Pixar they spend months
researching every aspect of their movies
to prepare for ratatouille
several members of the team flew to
France and spent two weeks visiting
kitchens and interviewing their chefs
they even trudged through the Paris
sewers where many a rat makes his home
when it was decided that call
federation's balloon propelled House
John when it was decided that car
frontage against balloon propelled
Frederickson okay when it was decided
that call Fredrickson's balloon
propelled house would sail to the
mountains of South America and up John
Lasseter chief creative officer Pixar
sent a group of artists to Venezuela to
see the mountains of clothes not only
that but an ostrich was brought into
Pixar's headquarters to inspire the
animators who are modeling the giant
bird this is what makes their movies
great I hope you enjoyed this video and
you feel like you're a better designer
than you were five minutes ago if you
want to submit your logo for a critique
here's how go to Facebook find our page
the futures here futures without an e
and look for posts that are calling for
your submission don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and hit that Bell
button see you guys next time